[Music]
this is a tough holiday season
okay we all want to see our families
this year but it's just not safe
the code infection rates are rising and
even a small
chance of passing on the virus is still
a chance and
i don't want to scare anyone and i don't
want to blow things out of proportion
but look if you're going to see your
family this christmas
you know what you might as well be
saying
i wanna kill you this christmas i wanna
show up at your house
i wanna kill you this christmas you and
your family and your spouse
you'll ring your doorbell answer and i
will say hello
it's time to die i wanna show up to your
house and kill you
this christmas you've been socially
distant i wanna visit you again
even though i've been everywhere with my
mask around my chin
you say wait till summer time but i will
not
cause i'm gonna show up to your house
and kill
you this christmas
now look is it likely that you'll die if
i show up to your house
no is it possible yes
do i love christmas so freaking bad that
i'd let it kill me
no now you might feel sad but you know
who's not sad
your parents i want your lazy ass around
no way
were you gonna help with the dishes the
stale ass
i wanna show up to your house
let me show up to your house can't wait
to show up to your house and kill you
this christmas
[Music]
[Applause]
you